[Music]
welcome to 3abn today Bible Q&A my name
is JD Quinn I'm going to be your host
today what a privilege it is to be part
of part of this team have you know
people around the world have lots of
questions I just want to be let everyone
know that the questions are coming from
you you'll notice that one of the
question is from Kenya today so it's
just not next door to us this is an
international Ministry that we have and
these questions come from all these
different places want to introduce our
special guest our team want to talk to
California California it's it's time for
the tomatoes to be sprouting out there
not sprouting but actually ready to eat
but anyway James how are you doing it's
wonderful to have you here it's always
good to see smiling face good doing good
JD it's good to be here with you all and
thankful again for this opportunity just
to to share the word amen pastor John
deny our good friend it's a blessing to
be here as well and Bible Q&A is a
program where we all get to learn a
little more about the Bible and about
the Lord amen amen and sister Shel Quinn
my precious wife amen good to see you
Shel we just enjoy doing this program so
much and want to thank you for your
participation because we're answering
your interesting questions and many
times it makes us study that much harder
harder amen it's one thing to uh to take
the time to look up the questions to
your uh look up the answers to your
questions but it's something else to be
able to get it down in that thre minute
form I mean there's what takes a lot of
time you know if I was to explain
something it' probably take 30 minutes
and boy to take it down to that 3
minutes 2 minutes four minutes
distilling it is the most difficult part
because we come with this long list of
scriptures and then we have to distill
it down and decide what to include how
do you contact us to be able to send
your questions to us that's a good
question right there number one if you
want to text it it's 618 228
3975 once again 618 228
3975 perhaps you'd like to email it to
us that's Bible QA at 3 ABM
.tv once again Bible QA
3abn.org
today we want to thank you Lord for this
opportunity to share you father these
are questions that people around the
world have sent in and so father we
thank you for uh the guests that we have
and for them taking the time lord
they've studied long they've studied
hard in order to be able to answer these
within the time limits so we just ask
Lord that uh the questions that are sent
in will indeed be answered they will be
appropriately answered Lord and father
be with all of uh the people that are
watching I just ask Lord that each one
has a special has a special relationship
with you so so we turn this time over to
you Lord and we have Thanksgiving in our
hearts in doing so we love you and thank
you in Jesus name amen
amen Pastor James I'm going to start
with you with the first question okay
okay the large day and the Sabbath seem
to be two completely different days is
this the same day of the Lord that some
are erroneously correlating Sunday the
day of the
Lord oh thank you for that important
question regarding the Lord's day the
Sabbath day and the day of the Lord
first let's look at the Lord's day and
the Sabbath then we'll look at the day
of the Lord so according to the Bible
the Lord's day and the Sabbath are one
in the same we'll look at a couple Bible
verses for example Exodus chap 20
beginning with verse 8 says remember the
Sabbath day to keep it holy six days
shalt thou labor and do all thy work but
the seventh day is the Sabbath of the
Lord thy God okay there it is right
there the seventh day is the Sabbath of
the Lord thy God in it Thou shalt not do
any work thou nor thy son nor thy
daughter thy maid servant thy manservant
nor thy cattle nor thy stranger that is
with in thy gates for in six days the
Lord made Heaven and Earth and the Sea
and all in the m and rested the seventh
day wherefore the Lord bless the Sabbath
day and hallowed it now that's uh
pointing back to Creation the seventh
day Sabbath that God blessed and set
laid aside at the creation of this Earth
so that is Saturday the seventh day and
that is according to these verses that
is the Lord's Day right it says right
here the seventh day is the Sabbath of
the Lord thy God in Mark chapter 2 27-28
Jesus says the Sabbath was made for man
that is for mankind not just for the
Jews because of course there were no
Jews when God created the Sabbath and
blessed it and laid it aside the Sabbath
was made for man and not man for the
Sabbath and then he says this re
reiterating what he said in Exodus 20
therefore the son of man is Lord also of
the Sabbath so the Lord's day is the
seventh day Sabbath Saturday now we can
see that clearly from these texts and
even Jesus says he's lord of the Sabbath
so what about the day of the Lord that's
a completely different day than the
seventh day Sabbath The Lord's Day the
day of the Lord is identified in
scriptures like Joel 1 ver1 15 which
says Al last for the day the day of the
Lord is at hand and as a destruction
from the almighty shall it come or Joel
chap 2 and verse one blow ye the trumpet
in Zion sound an alarm in my Holy
Mountain let all the inhabitants of the
land tremble for the day of the Lord
cometh it is nigh at hand so the day of
the Lord refers to the day of judgment
accompanied by God's righteous wrath
against evil and wickedness and this we
see as the second coming of Jesus Christ
let me give you another verse here it's
Isaiah 13:9 behold the day of the Lord
comes cruel both with Wrath W and fierce
anger to lay the land desolate and he
shall destroy the Sinners thereof out of
it in fact we see the same thing in the
New Testament if we go to 1
Thessalonians chapter 5: 1-3 Paul is
talking about the times and the seasons
he says Brethren you don't need to know
about the times and the seasons you
yourselves know perfectly 1
Thessalonians chapter 5: two that the
day of the Lord the what the day of the
Lord shall come as a thief in the night
and then it goes on to say in this
context so when they shall say peace and
safety then sudden destruction cometh
upon them as travail upon a woman with
child and they shall not Escape you can
also look at Zephaniah chapter 1 1418 oh
there are many verses on the day of the
Lord in the Bible so the Lord's Day
refers to the seventh day Sabbath
Saturday the day of the Lord refers to
the day of God's Wrath and specifically
the second coming of Jesus Christ amen
amen very well put
Pastor
deny when Jesus rose from the tomb they
did not recognize him maybe because he
had a glorified body but with some scars
and a new robe is that how it will be
when people rise from the dead at the
second coming and get a new
robe thank you for that question
um first of all the question the uh the
cases you mentioned um there was a
different reason why they were not
recognized uh we don't have time to
enter into that but uh I want to uh
mention to you that there's no
indication in the Bible that we will
have scars in our body actually the only
scars that will remain after all is said
and done we have a new Earth and we're
in heaven and then here on Earth in the
new Earth um the only scars That Remain
is the scars in the that Jesus had from
the crucifixion hands uh forehead and of
course uh the pier side and the feet so
those are the only scars that remain
that will remind us of the world that
was before everything else will be gone
the world will be made new we will have
new bodies we will have no scars and we
will be a new creation in Jesus Christ
let's take a look at 1 Corinthians
chapter 15 we'll begin in verse 40 there
are also celestial bodies and
terrestrial bodies but the glory of the
celestial is one and the glory of the
terrestrial is another there is one
glory of the Sun and another glory of
the Moon and another glory of the stars
for one star differs from another star
in glory so also is the resurrection of
the Dead the body is sown in corruption
it is raised in incorruption it is sown
in dishonor it is raised in glory it is
sown in weakness it is raised in power
it is swn a natural body it is raised a
spiritual body there is a natural body
and here is a spiritual body so this is
a new body that we will receive 1
Corinthians uh 15 now we move to uh
verse 50 now this I say Brethren that
flesh and blood cannot inherit the
kingdom of God nor does corruption
inherit incorruption behold I tell you a
mystery we shall not all sleep but we
shall all be changed in a moment in the
twinkling of an eye at the last trumpet
for the trumpet will sound and the dead
will be raised
Incorruptible and we shall be changed
for this corruptible that's what we have
now must put on incorruption and this
Mortal must put on immortality we do not
have immortality there's nothing in us
that has immortality nothing in us that
is eternal including what some people
call the soul we won't have time to get
into that right now so when this
corruptible that's what we have now has
put on incorruption and this Mortal has
put on immortality then shall be brought
to pass the saying that it is written
death is swallowed up in Victory so we
are going to get new bodies no scars and
of course uh we will have a robe of
righteousness that we get because of the
perfect life of Jesus Christ he paid for
our sins and he has uh redeemed us and
we shall be able to have eternal life
because of his great sacrifice for us
amen well put
Shelly your number one question was the
story of the woman with the alabaster
ointment the same person in all four
gospels are were the two different
people and this is coming from
Iowa this is something that really
interested me one thing I've learned
when you're studying an event in one
gospel look for it in each gospel each
one of the gospel writers wrote to
different audiences including different
details as they gave their perspective
one thing that um we know about this
story it was an act of self sacrificing
love it was an act of AD
adoration Jesus says both in Matthew
2613 and Mark
149 assuredly I say to you this is the
woman who's just anointed his feet and
his head he said assuredly I say to you
where ever this gospel is preached in
the whole world what this woman has done
will also be told as a memorial to her
wherever the gospel is preached and all
four gospels tell this story this is a
woman at the feast who it's a supper
time and she anoints jesus' feet and
some say his head so what we're going to
do real quickly just write these
references down we'll look at the
parallels found in all four gospels
where did this happened it happened at
Bethany the house of Simon a Pharisee
who was healed of
leprosy now we see Matthew Mark and John
all explain it happens in Bethany where
Lazarus has been raised from the dead um
only John or Matthew Mark and Luke
identify it as Simon's house so we see
the parallel only John doesn't mention
that it was Simon's house but we
obviously see it's the same house when
the final when did it happen it was the
final week before Judas
betrayed Jesus Matthew Mark and John say
it was the final week before the
crucifixion Luke's
gospel he wrote in an orderly account
with a lot of historical detail but not
in a strict chronological
account and how did it happen Matthew
Mark and Luke mentioned it was the
alabaster box or flask Matthew says it
was very costly fragrant oil Mark says
it's very costly oil of nard Luke
says it's fragrant oil John doesn't
mention the alabaster flask but he
describes it as a very a pound of very
costly oil of spikenard so we see that
agreement Matthew says she poured it
over his head and his body Mark just
says she poured it on her feet Luke says
she anoints his feet wipes her hair with
it John said she anoints his feet and
wipes her hair with it now who do they
describe Matthew and Mark she's an
unnamed woman Luke she's an unnamed
woman who's
identified as a sinner and most likely
Mary Magdalene was still alive then and
that's why they don't name her Mary
Magdalene was a devout follower of
Christ healed from Seven evil spirits
all four gospels have her at the cross
uh she Matthew and Mark said she
observed where his body was laid all for
have her at the empty tomb on Sunday
morning the resurrected Christ we find
in Mark and John both
agree appeared to Mary first
now only John names her and this is
decades later Mary was most likely dead
at this point now listen to this John 11
1-3 now a certain man was sick Lazarus
of Bethany the town of Mary and her
sister Martha it was that Mary the
sister of Lazarus and Martha who
anointed the Lord with fragrant oil
wiped his feet with her hair whose
brother Lazarus was
sick therefore the sister sent to him
saying Lord behold he whom you love is
sick then he tells the whole story
repeats the story in John 12 1-7 so
here's the
point John records the same words that
Jesus spoke to this woman in in that
Matthew and Mark record that Jesus said
why do you trouble the woman for the
poor you have with me always but me you
do not always have she's done a good
work for me she did it for my burial the
woman who was identified as a sister
then as the Mary of Bethany I think it's
reasonable to assume that she is when
Mary was younger she had moved away to
Bethany she fell into sin she ended up
coming home to Martha and Lazarus and
then was called Mary of uh Bethany amen
amen
good James your second question the
Bible states that no one knows the date
or the hour of Christ's second coming no
man no angel not even the son but the
father only how is that possible if
God if if the son is also God he should
know when he's coming can you please
explain that's a great question first
let's look at a couple of verses that
talk about this Mark
1332 but that day and hour knoweth no
man know not the Angels which are in
heaven neither the son but the father
Matthew
24:36 but of that day and hour knoweth
no man no not the angels of heaven but
my father only you notice that Matthew
24:36 leaves out nor the Sun so
Matthew's gospel doesn't include the Sun
and not knowing I think there's a reason
for that as we look at a couple more
verses we're going to discover that
reason now the only way we might imagine
that this knowledge is unknown to Christ
would be in his human form wherein
Christ has laid aside his divinity for
33 and a half years in this human sense
one might suggest that Christ could
include himself as not knowing the day
of his return but clearly that temporary
limitation of itions is no longer
applicable since Christ has ascended to
heaven to take his rightful place in the
godhead so while on Earth speaking of
his Humanity completely surrendered to
the father Jesus could say no man nor
the angels nor myself knows the hour of
my return only the Father in Heaven
because Jesus as a man may not have
known that hour as a man the Bible says
in for example Luke chap 2 and: 15 2
Jesus increased in wisdom and stature
and favor with God and man Jesus grew in
knowledge just like humans have to to do
uh as a man he learned from Reading
God's word just as we have to do as a
man Jesus laid aside his omnicient his
all- knowing power and trusted to the
power of his father and Jesus is
presented to to us now restored to his
divinity he along with the father now
shares a knowledge of the day and the
hour of his return and this is confirmed
by the following Verses first of all
notice Matthew chap 28 and: 18 and Jesus
came and spake unto them his disciples
and said all power is given unto me in
heaven and in Earth this is the
resurrected Christ who is saying this
now notice what he says in Acts chapter
1 16 and 7 when they therefore were come
together they asked him this is the
resurrected CH Christ saying Lord will
thou at this time restore again the
Kingdom of Israel and he said unto them
is not for you to know the times and the
seasons which the father ha put in his
own power which by the way is the power
that's also been given to Jesus so here
we see that all power has been restored
to Jesus Christ as the resurrected
savior this time Jesus doesn't say that
he doesn't know the hour of the
restoration of the Kingdom but rather he
says it's not for you the disciples to
know that his divinity along with the
father is now shared he is included in
that power that knowledge of the day of
his return
he is included in that understanding as
he is a resurrected Lord and Savior I
hope this is helpful in answering your
question am thank you thank you Johnny
this is from Bonnie in Mississippi can
you please explain 1 Corinthians
10:
23-33 thank you so much for that
question uh first I want to say that
there is no indication in the Bible
that it has ever become okay to eat
unclean food God made a distinction of
clean and unclean foods for a reason a
reason of health and so please take into
consideration that unclean foods are
those mainly that eat those things that
are dead decaying and in a state of uh
putrification I think that's a good word
putrification and so eating those things
that eat uh those things can be harmful
to our health so having that in mind
let's take into consideration uh Paul uh
he said in Philippians 35 and 6
concerning himself circumcised The
Eighth Day of the stock of Israel of The
Tribe of Benjamin and Hebrew of the
Hebrews as touching the law a Pharisee
concerning Zeo persecuting the church
touching the righteousness which is in
the law blameless Paul obeyed the law of
God and he would be careful to uh keep
himself away from unclean food so what
is this talking about here this is
talking about animals offered to Idol
this is what Paul is referring referring
to in the scriptures you have mentioned
now uh look at the context First
Corinthians First Corinthians chapter
10: 23 uh through 33 okay but the
context the remote context and the
immediate context remote context I began
in First Corinthians chapter 8 and
notice what it says in verse three now
concerning things offered to Idols this
is what he's talking about we know that
we have that we all have knowledge
knowledge puffs up but Love edifies
Therefore concerning the eating of
things offered to Idols we know that an
idol is nothing in the world and there
is no other God but one so basically
he's saying you know these Idol is not
really anything so if you don't know
that it's been offered to an idol you go
ahead and eat it this is what he is
saying there uh but this goes back to a
time when there was a meeting between
the elders and the F and the U uh the he
others and apostles Acts chapter 15 28-
29 when this was forbidden to eat of
foods offered to Idols look what it says
here for it seemed good to the Holy
Spirit and to us to lay upon you no
greater burden than these necessary
things that you abstain from things
offered to Idols from blood from things
strangled and from sexual immorality if
you keep yourselves from this you will
do well let's go quickly to 1
Corinthians chapter 10 and get the
context of that if any of those who do
not believe which verse 1 Corinthians
chap 10: 27 if any of those who do not
believe invites you to dinner and you
desire to go eat whatever is said before
you asking no questions for conscience
sake he's talking about Foods offered to
Idols but if anyone says to you this is
offered to Idols you see do not eat of
it for the sake of the one who told you
and for uh conscience sake for the Earth
is the Lord's and all its fullness this
is what he's talking about things
offered to Idol conscience I say not
your own but that of the other for why
is my Liberty judged by another man's
conscience but if I if I partake with
thanks why am I evil spoken up for the
food over which I give thanks therefore
whether you eat or drink talking about
Foods offered to Idols or whatever you
do do all to the glory of God give no
offense either to the Jews or to the
Greeks or to the Church of God just as I
also please all men in all things not
seeking my own Prophet but the prophet
of many that they may be saved so this
is not talking about eating clean and
unclean Foods uh those animals that are
unclean are still not the healthiest
choice for you you can eat clean animals
but the unclean animals it is safer for
you for me and for everyone to stay away
from them amen amen Shelly your second
question yes can one live for god
without the Holy
Spirit no
let me give you the scripture says no
let me give you seven quick scripture
references Acts 2
38-39 Acts 2 38-39 this is Peter at
Pentecost he says repent and let every
one of you be baptized in the name of
Jesus Christ for the remission of your
sins you shall receive the gift of the
holy spirit for the promises to you and
to your children to all who are a far
off as many as the Lord Our God will
call so we see all Christians receive
the gift of the Holy Spirit Romans 8 and
verse 9 Paul says if anyone does not
have the spirit of Christ he is not his
and he goes on in Romans 8: 14 and 15 to
say as many as are led by the spirit of
God these are the sons this is a
covenant term it includes us women too
but these are the sons of God for you
did not receive the spirit of bondage
again to fear but you received the
spirit of adoption by whom we cry out
ABA father First Corinthians 2:14 says
the natural man does not receive the
things of the spirit of God they
foolishness to him nor can he know them
because they are spiritually discerned
the things of the spirit the word of God
is spiritually discerned pray for the
holy spirit before you read because only
by him can you understand and Jesus said
in John
16:13 whenever he the spirit of Truth
has come he will guide you into all
truth Ephesians 3:16-17
Ephesians 3:16-17 be strengthened with
might through his spirit in the inner
man that Christ May dwell in Your Heart
by faith faith that you be will be
rooted and grounded in love and finally
um Philippians 2:13 says Paul says it is
God who works in you to Will and to do
his good pleasure by the power of the
Holy Spirit he changes our desires our
will and then as we step out in faith he
gives us the power to obey you cannot
serve God you cannot live for god
without the the holy spirit amen good
answer thank you I want to take just a
second real uh and just give you have
the contact list again if you want to
text in your uh questions 618 228
3975 if you'd like to email them Bible
QA 3abn.org
official James number
three yes sir this is a good this is a a
long question it's a good question I
want to do the right thing so I'm asking
you for your help I no longer work due
to health concerns I do receive
disability benefits do I return ties and
offerings from this I need to know
what's right so I can do what's expected
of me I don't want to Rob God I've been
faithful when I was working by returning
my tithes and offerings so I don't want
to mess up now and this is from
Cynthia hi Cynthia this is an important
question I love your heart toward God so
pensions earnings wages disability
inheritance gifts winnings any increase
that we receive we are they're all
eligible for tithes and offerings we
return tithe on our increase just uh not
just on our our wages so it's just we
tithe our increase and of course you
know that you've been paying tithes
you've been paying offerings for for
years so as you know tithe is God's it's
not ours it's not something we give to
God it's something we return to him and
it's not a payment or a bill rather it's
a faith statement in God when we return
tied to God we're making a faith
statement that we have faith in our
father and our God that he's going to
take care of us when we return tith we
say God owns everything that we have and
we receive and all things come of him
and of him and of our own we have we
have given him of his own we have given
him that's 1 Corinthians chapter excuse
me 1 Chronicles chapter 29:14 one of my
favorite scriptures on this subject when
we return tied we accept his challenge
to prove him that he would not open up
the windows of heaven right Malachi CH
3:10 when we return tith we trust that
God will give back to us blessings that
we will not have room enough to receive
again Malachi 3:10 when we return tithe
we have the privilege of partnering with
God and taking the gospel to all the
world right 1 Corinthians uh chapter n
the whole chapter talks about Paul
encouraging the Believers to work with
him to supply of the bre so the gospel
go to all the world we return tithe We
Lay Up treasure in heaven Jesus says in
Matthew chapter 6 and verse 20 and when
we return tithe even though it's a small
amount maybe it's just a might a Widow's
might we place our full trust in God to
take care of us according to Mark 12
41-44 so when we return to tithe we let
go of more and more of our of our trust
in Earthly possessions right Matthew
6:33 um you know seek ye first the
kingdom of God and all these Earthly
possessions will be added unto your food
your rment your everything that you need
so when we return time basically we're
divesting ourselves more and more of
self of self- dependence of
self-reliance of materialism and we're
putting our trust more and more in
Christ and you can look at a few more
verses Genesis 28:22 of course Malachi 3
8-12 and Matthew 61
19-21 and Luke 21 1-3 so I hope this is
helpful and remember you can't outgive
God but it is fun
trying amen amen great answer very nice
Johnny yes sir your third question will
there come a time when people will
search for the word of God and will not
find it as explained in Amos 8
11-2 has this ever happened before in
history can you do a comparison between
Amos 8 11 and 12 and Jeremiah
2913 and this is from Anthony in
Ohio thank you Anthony uh uh for your
question uh it is very interesting the
way you phrase the question because you
asked has this ever happened and when we
say the word of the lord it's also in
essence saying looking for the lord and
there uh I can bring to you your
attention uh during the time of the
flood Noah preached for 120 years and
eventually the Lord said go into the ark
the animals were already in go into the
ark you and your family so Noah goes
into the ark and now it begins to rain
after 7 Days Later begins to rain and
the water is starting to uh go higher
and higher now people realize hey what
he was saying is true there's going to
be a flood and this doesn't seem to be
stopping so now they want to search the
Lord they want to hear the truth they
are knocking on the door of the Ark they
want to get in but it is too late so in
essence they are looking for the lord
they're looking for a good word from the
Lord but it became too late the door was
Clos so in essence you can say that at
this time um something similar to what
is found in Amos 8 11-12 has happened
let's go to Jeremiah
29:13 and you will seek me and find me
when you search for me with all your
heart this is a promise from the Lord
that if we seek him with all of our
hearts we will find him he's not hard to
find because he is searching for us we
see this example in the parable of the
lost sheep Jesus himself said I have
come to seek and to save that which was
lost so he's looking for us he's also
pictured in Revelation 3:20 behold I
stand at the door and knock so he is
looking for us he is calling us and he
is trying to attract uh us to him so
what about Amos 8 uh: 11-2 let's take a
look at them notice the words Behold the
days are coming in other words a time is
coming says the Lord God that I will
send a famine on the land not a famine
of bread nor a thirst for water but of
hearing the words of the Lord so there's
going to come a time when the Lord is
going to withdraw himself because the
the door of Mercy is going to close and
no more can you repent and actually the
work has been done the gospel has been
preached and every individual that can
repent has repented and I say can repent
that means choose to repent because we
can all choose to repent we can all
choose to leave the world of sin and
follow Jesus and this is why Jesus is
pictured as knocking at the door but the
time will come when no one else will
repent and the Lord the Holy Spirit Will
withdraw and uh when people see
calamities And when they see those
plagues some may try to find the Lord
but it will be too late uh so they shall
Wander from sea to Sea and from North to
East they shall run to and fr seeking
the word of the Lord but shall not find
it so Isaiah 556 and 7 seek the Lord
while he may be found call upon him
while he is near amen very good Shelly
right third question if Christian
Believers go to heaven what's the
purpose of the new Earth who will live
on the new Earth and who will live in
the New Jerusalem and this is from
Bonnie in Georgia Bonnie this is a great
question
the righteous go to heaven for a
thousand years we see in Revelation 20:
4-6 Revelation
24-6 this is the first resurrection it
says and they lived and reigned with
Christ for a thousand years and the
second death has no power over them so
while we're there God's going to open
the Heavenly record books we'll get to
review this and understand his right
rightous judgment on who was
disqualified and maybe why some of us
made it and in verse five of Revelation
20 it says the rest of the Dead did not
live again until the thousand years were
over so the unrighteous Dead who are
killed by the brightness of his
coming lie in Desolation on Earth for
that Thousand Years Jeremiah 4:23 said I
beheld the Earth indeed it was without
form and void he's this is after the day
of the Lord and Revelation 20 verse two
says that Satan is Bound for those
thousand years this is symbolic he is
bound by circumstances there's no one
alive for him to tempt and so in
Revelation uh 20 and verse two it talks
about the second resurrection of the
wicked The Condemned the final judge Jud
ment when God will turn the Earth he
destroyed the earth once with a lake of
water he will destroy at the second time
with a lake of fire and this will be the
second death that's mentioned four times
in Revelation so he recreates the Earth
it's Eden restored the New Jerusalem let
let me just read this to you Revelation
21 1-4 some of my favorite scriptures
Revelation 21 1-4 now I saw a new Heaven
and a new Earth for the first Heaven and
Earth had passed away and then he says I
John saw the holy city the New Jerusalem
coming down out of Heaven from God
prepared as a bride adorned for her
husband and I heard a loud voice saying
behold the Tabernacle of God is with men
he will dwell with them they shall be
his people people God himself will be
with them and be their God and God will
wipe away every tear from their eyes
there's no more death sorrow crying no
more pain for the former things have
passed away so after that thousand years
in heaven we come we dwell on the new
Earth which is God's command Central
it's his Universal headquarters and life
in the new Earth will be just like what
Adam and Eve we've experienced in the
Garden of Eden it's going to be
wonderful amen very
well James your last question what is
the meaning of Colossians
2:16 and this is from Walter down in
Nairobi
Kenya great question Walter thank you so
much let's just take a look at the text
Colossians chapter
26 is in its context a very important
text it says here let's just start with
verse 13 and you being dead in your sins
and your your uncircumcision of your
flesh has be quickened together with him
having forgiven you all your trespasses
blotting out the handwriting of
ordinances that was against us which was
contrary to us he took it out of the way
nailing it to the cross and having
spoiled principalities and Powers he
made a show of them openly triumphing
over them in it let no man therefore
judge you in meat or in drink or in
respect of an holy day or of the new
moon or of the Sabbath days which are a
shadow of things to come but the body is
of Christ so what does this mean well
the context of this is dealing with
Jewish converts and Gentile converts
Jewish and Gentile Believers in the
faith and they had different backgrounds
different challenges and the context of
the focus of these verses is primarily
dealing with the ceremonial laws which
were all fulfilled in Christ as it came
as as related to the sacrifice the
Priestly Ministry the Earthly Tabernacle
that's why when Christ died the veil of
the temple was written too from top to
bottom it ended the sacrificial service
which was a type or a shadow of the
reality in heaven and that reality was
fulfilled in Jesus as the Pascal lamb as
the sacrificial lamb and also as the
high priest after the order of mzc uh
Hebrews chapter 8 really emphasizes this
Hebrews 8 Hebrews 9 Christ is in the uh
Heavenly Sanctuary now he's ministering
there for us at his Ascension in the
Holy place at 1844 he went into the most
holy place but the focus is judging
don't let Believers judge other believes
in relationship to these specific
practices now there were many Jews who
had a hard time giving out the
ceremonial practices okay the the the
the difficulty was that they had
practiced these things for centuries
they'd come down through their uh
ancestors the Gentiles on the other hand
had no problem with it at all like they
didn't even know about it so what was
the what was the issue and there became
the began to be a little bit of a uh
judgmentalism that arose among Believers
Paul talks about this in Romans 14 in
detail and he says listen don't judge
one another in respect to uh you know
the day you worship or respect to the
things that you eat let every man be
fully persuaded in his own mind we're
all going to stand before the Judgment
seat of Christ now some people try to
say that these verses are doing away
with the 7eventh day Sabbath no there's
no place in the Bible where that is
indicated these Sabbath days had to do
with the ceremony laws the main Central
focus of these verses and the verses in
Romans 14 and in other places are the
focus of judging people in relation to
the ceremonial laws which were fulfilled
in Christ if the Jews wanted to keep
them please don't put that on the
Gentiles the Gentiles aren't keeping
them don't judge them for that uh let
every man be fully persuaded and be
together in the faith without these
critical negative feelings about that
which Christ has fulfilled amen well
answered
Johnny yes sir number
four is Satan the king of TI this is
from Crystal thank you very much that's
a good question and uh we have to go to
the scripture for that and I want to say
something first there was a literal king
of Ty in some Bibles says Tyrus but
there was a literal king of TI but he
became so puffed up because of his
authority and so much power that he had
that he actually began to think he's a
god there are people even today that
somehow they think they're a God but
they are not and so let's go ahead and
go to Ezekiel chapter 28 and you begin
to see that this man uh thought he was a
god Ezekiel 28 beginning in verse one
the word of the Lord came to me again
saying son of man say to the prince of
Ty thus says the Lord God because your
heart is lifted up and you say I am a
God I sit in the seat of gods in the
midst of the Seas you yet you are a man
and not a god though you set your heart
as the heart of a God so this man uh
this king of Ty was so evil and
identified so much in his
characteristics to the devil that he is
used as a symbol of the devil uh
actually the covering Cher of Lucifer
that eventually became the devil when he
rebelled uh in heaven and became Satan
and also called the dragon and the devil
so let's go ahead now and look at some
verses that are found in Ezekiel 28 that
helps us to understand that it is no
longer talking about a literal King
notice Ezekiel 28 and it says in verse
uh 13 thou has been in Eden the Garden
of God question has any human being been
in the garden of God after Adam and Eve
sinned no because Angels were placed at
the gate so that no human being could
enter therein so this king of tire that
was a literal King could not be the one
that is being referred to in Ezekiel
28:13 notice now verse 14 Thou Art the
anointed cherub that cth thou was upon
the holy mountain of God two other clues
that help us to understand it is not
talking about a literal man a literal
King this is now a symbol that we're
talking about and again uh look at verse
15 thou was perfect in thy ways from the
day that thou was created till iniquity
was found in thee I only have enough
time to tell you that God created a
perfect angel with nothing wrong with
this Angel but he of his own choice
corrupted himself so God did not place
like a a default in him that eventually
after a certain period of time he would
become evil no he of his own choice
decided to become evil so now let's go
uh to verse 16 notice What God Says I
will cast thee as profane out of the
Mountain of God he was cast out of
Heaven the devil was and I will destroy
thee old covering cherub so again we see
here that is making a reference to a
symbol king of Ty was a little man but
became a symbol of the devil that's very
good amen
amen Shelly your fourth
question are the great white Throne
judgment and the Judgment seat of Christ
the same event are are they two separate
events and this is from Michael and
Marilyn all right Michael what a
wonderful question something that uh
always intrigued me as well and I've
studied it deeply write these references
down if you have a pen and paper please
2 Corinthians 5 and verse 10 2
Corinthians 5:1 says for we must all
appear before the Judgment seat of
Christ that each one may receive the
things done in the body according to
what he has done whether good or bad now
I'm going to say something that sounds
strange but listen he's not talking
about moral good or moral evil Christ
paid the penalty for that sin what and
Christ is our judge and our advocate he
is our defense attorney he represents us
what he's referring to is
determining
rewards for the use of our energy our
talent our gifts in ways that glorified
God for Eternal value
salvation and
rewards are determined before Christ
returns for his righteous Covenant
keeping people Revelation 2212 he says
behold I am coming quickly and my reward
is with me to give to everyone according
to his work now when he takes his
faithful Believers to heaven for a
thousand years we see in Revelation 20
and verse 5 at the end of those Thousand
Years the rest of the Dead are raised
you know Jesus said in John 528 and 29
that all who are in their grave will
hear his voice some come forth to the
resurrection of life that's the first
resurrection and some come forth to the
resurrection of
condemnation this is what Revelation 20
and verse 5 is talking about that the
these are raised in the second
resurrection of
condemnation so now let's read
Revelation
20: 11-1
15 after the second Resurrection it says
then I saw a great white throne and him
who sat on it from whose face the earth
and the heaven fled away and there was
no place found for them and I saw the
Dead He's referring back to verse
five that the wicked from the second
Resurrection small and great standing
before God books were open and another
book was opened which is The Book of
Life and the dead were judged according
to their works by the things which were
written in the books the sea gave up the
Dead who were in it and death and Hades
Hades is the ground delivered up the
Dead who were in them or Hades is the
grave I should say and they were judged
each one according to his works then
death and Hades were cast into the Lake
of Fire this is the second death that's
what it says right here and then he says
anyone
not found written in the Book of Life
was cast into the Lake of Fire you know
he goes on John in Revelation
218 he says the Cowardly the unbelieving
the abominable murderers sexually
immoral Sorcerers those who practice
Witchcraft
idolators and all liars shall have their
part in the lake which burns with fire
and brimstone which is the second death
so The Condemned are raised for God's
righteous great white Throne judgment to
be cast into the Lake of Fire to utterly
perish they're going to experience the
second death and as I said earlier just
as God once cleansed the Earth of all
sin by a lake of water at the end of
time he will turn this Earth into a lake
of fire and Purge all
unrighteousness from the earth and it's
he's sin and sinners will rise no more
you know in Jude 7 I wanted to point
this out there's only one chapter in
Jude so Jude verse
7 Sodom and gomore are said to have been
set forth as an example of s offering
the Vengeance of Eternal fire that is
relative that word Eternal to what it's
describing Sodom and Gomorrah burn no
more when the earth becomes a lake of
fire it's going to burn up all sin and
sinners it will not be quenched until it
finishes its work and those in the great
white judgment will perish amen thank
you thank you I want to thank you for
this St we're going to take probably
about a minute for an address roll and
we'll come back with some final
thoughts if you're enjoying our 3abn
Bible Q&A then tell your friends each
Monday we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA 3abn.org
that's Bible qa3
[Music]
abn.com back any final thoughts
guys yeah I just really appreciate each
of the answers you'll notice our viewers
will notice that when these questions
come in right away we go to the word of
God we usually go right to the verse
that's being uh talked about or asked
about and then we go to other Bible
verses like for example the question on
the Lord's Day versus the Sabbath day
versus the day of the Lord and you'll
notice also that when we go to these
Bible verses these Bible verses really
clarify what the question is asking
about you know we looked at Exodus
chapter 20 for example where we were
told that the Sabbath day is the is the
the day of the Lord and also that Jesus
says that the Sabbath is his day and
then we looked at other verses that
talked about the day of the Lord coming
as Vengeance with uh wrath and of course
that was referring to the second coming
of Jesus and likewise with each one of
the questions I really appreciated the
answers because consistently we're going
to the word of God and friends we just
want to remind you that it's the word of
God that is going to keep you in these
last days we all have our opinions we
all have our ideas but you want people
that going to go to the word of God you
want to be faithful Brans yourselves and
when you hear people preach and teach
you want to take their words back to the
word of God and make sure that it's true
amen amen amen well I would like to go
back to the question you know the
question is asked about people searching
for the word of God word of God and will
there be a time when God will not be
found and so once again I go back to
Isaiah 556 and 7 seek the Lord while he
may be found call upon him while he is
near let the wicked forsake his way and
the unrighteous man his thoughts let him
return to the Lord and He will have
mercy on him and to our God for he will
abundantly pardon and it is time to get
that done amen and all I want to say is
never separate the love of God from the
truth of God if you do you have
destroyed the power of the Gospel amen I
want to go out with this right here but
as far as me I trust in you oh Lord
Jesus you are my God make your face
shine upon your servant and save me for
your mercy sake God bless you amen
[Music]